all right for people who are joining
this live stream this is part of a
design discussion about arrays in modern
language
and this is uh
i don't know which part number it is but
uh
uh
it seems like we had two recent meetings
right let's just summarize
roughly where we think we are
trying to get to and then we will see a
demo of a piece of this
so the first issue is what we were
calling before scaffolded arrays
that is
arrays which are really
have in them
some of their dimensions are
associations
some
they may have units they might
conceivably have missings and things
like that in them
but the goal is that the internal
storage of those arrays
is in some very raw form and normally
that internal storage would be a
traditional array although one can
imagine that that internal storage could
be swapped out and be for example a
linked list or an out of core object
but the concept is that there is a an
outer wrapper that handles kind of the
transformation from
for example a part number that's being
requested to the actual raw part
specification needed for the inner
representation of the array
is that other people's understanding of
this situation also
yes no well that that's what we were
discussing the last couple of meetings i
don't think that's the entirety of the
discussion that needs to be had but no i
understand that but
so i think one of the things that we've
we've talked about with scaffolded
arrays
is
what kinds of operations should a
scaffolded array support
is it part extraction what about
transpose
those kinds of things
and i mean i think
where we want to
maybe i want to make a yet a new
uh set of notes here
um
and uh
uh or should we just edit this these
notes here um because i think that
um
this is a quantity object but there's a
symbol for it on demand okay so there's
also there's also things like global
array operations
eg
transpose and how do those work
but there's mostly the sort of the api
that is exposed by scaffolded array for
example
and how that works
one thing about transpose
i think it's it's kind of important that
uh
we
i mean at the very least at the lower
level the only operations that will be
support absolutely by all kinds of
things are things that keep i mean if it
was a columnar
table it has to say a kilometer table
under the hood so if we do sport
transpose we will fake it
yeah in all things that things that are
not uh homeomorphisms in this
algebra should not be supported
so it's okay
what is
maintained in the wrapper
versus
what changes the underlying data
right so for example it could be the
case
eg
you know
uh details of missings
could be in the wrapper
uh
you know the knowledge that things were
transposed could be in the wrapper
does that make sense
well there's some things i mean
they made two questions i mean the first
one
so so one of the things we talked about
before
was you know that that we'd at least
initially have sort of a visible top
level
uh
visible top level head for these things
but that later it might be nice to turn
these into some sort of invisible packed
array like thing
so if for example exactly
i think that's that's a real mistake
right because you're basically going to
break everybody's code when you do that
oh you're not yes you are i mean if you
wrote all your code expecting this
rapper and suddenly the rapper
disappears well no no what it will look
like is
you just got an ordinary list you didn't
get one of these things well no no i
think i think it's also so at least what
we talked about last time is that we'd
keep the rappers right and it would be
like you know so so to use the packed
array analogy there'd be a head called
packed array and if you use it you know
you can you can use all your list
operations on it and it will make it'll
keep the head packed array but anytime
that some operation would unpack it
it'll you know complain
um
but then but then also if you have a
list it might secretly use the packed
array right so you can still if you've
written your code to use the explicit
packed array that code wouldn't change
it's just that we'd also use it secretly
in other cases
i mean that's that's understanding what
we talked about last time yeah
well i i think that would make sense it
will also make sense to have something
like i don't think
to have a
i think we need something that is a
little bit more general than factory
which is like
let's call it for now uh you know
scaffolded array which is like it
doesn't tell you what the underlying
implementation is and then but if you
really really want to know what the
underlying implementation is you use
something like data structure which
might be slightly different out of core
and whatnot
but it's like
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
scaffolded array will be something where
you can index into it you can get pieces
out of it you can do operations on it it
has all kinds of up values associated
with it
scaffolded array could have multiple un
internal
data data
representations um
okay and
you could probably use information to
find out which one it's actually using
right i think that's what carlos is
saying
but
yeah but i i guess that's really
valuable for people also if you know if
you just want the raw thing
uh
you know and it's like and it's a
database table and you happen to know at
least some sql and you want to like
really go at it
and then then we have something which
has string methods and it's very low
level but it's very efficient
and very cool that's fine but that's
that's a question of how
you know can you extract the data
structure that's inside a scaffolded
array but you know most of the time you
don't want to do that because scaffolded
array has all kinds of wrapper
information that maps you know
the for example
in the if it's stored in a database
it's going to have
you know you're going to be able to have
keys that aren't just numbers if it's
stored as a raw array
the
you know the various labels of the
dimensions are just numbers or just
integers
right and so but scaffolded array would
take care of mapping
you know a to one b to two and so on
so you don't want to go inside or you'll
be completely confused about what's
going on
does that make sense yeah
yeah but on the other hand it would like
it would make
make for a nice interface but like say
one implementation is responsibility of
some group and another implementation is
responsibilities on group like at least
we would have something like for the
underlying data structure things that
need to be supported so you can put it
into scaffolded array
sure
yeah that seems to be different from
what you were just saying
the fact that yes scaffolded array needs
an internal and an external api that
defines what's going on and
i mean i i think
i think we basically agree on this
concept now the question of whether
scaffold array can internally be
implemented in certain cases in you know
some apache arrow or whatever else thing
is
you know
like graph like other kinds of things
there should be multiple possible
internal representations that are all
transparently accessible using the top
level scaffolded array mechanism do we
agree
yeah i mean i think i think carlo my my
understanding what you were saying was
that you just want there to be in
addition to them being
you know exposed through scaffolded
array you also want them to be exposed
through some data structure like
mechanism where it's very explicit what
you're using is that
yeah
no that seems fine
but okay but i'm actually so sorry i
mean the reason i was bringing up the
invisible case is because there's
you know because we because as carla
brought up the case of like if you if
you uh you know these things should be
homeomorphisms
but i guess the
in the invisible case like if you had an
invisible quantity array and you mapped
over it
you know you don't know whether the
output is also going to be a quantity
right i mean i assume that this issue
has to be dealt with with hacked arrays
in some way but i don't really know how
it works
but
do you get what i mean i mean you can't
you can't complain if your if your
invisible data structures is turned into
another kind of invisible data structure
i i think in that case i am not sure
that in that case it would go through
scaffold array because
um
i mean at that when you are at that
level let's say
we have i mean we implement something
through arrow and we figure out that
there is a nice way to have an in-memory
packed array of strings which
underneath is using arrow
now arrow will support only maybe a
fraction of the many things we can do to
strings in the language like for example
you can't turn it into symbols
and stay within arrow
so
maybe
the arrow implemented version of the
pact array of strings can only do a
certain number of things without
unpacking but it certainly will use
directly the arrow interface lower level
and not go through scaffolded array
because you don't want that to work with
a column of strings on the database only
in memory arrow for example so i'm
saying i'm i'm confused i don't
understand i i think in the invisible
case it has to just normalize and
do whatever
and which point it's sort of
lost its utilities
[Music]
is that what
is that is that what pact array does
though i mean like does if you map over
a packed array i mean does it does it
basically just normalize it map over it
and then look at it when it's done and
say oh can i pack this yes i'll repack
it again
no that's not how it works
that's not how it works
so how does it work
i mean the old compiler so you
you know and so if it's compilable and
when the new compiler is faster it'll
use the new compiler so it it runs what
if the function f is compilable and
knows it's type signature
is that what would you say
type signature is compatible with the
type of data of
factory you have
it'll yeah well that's that's so in
other words
okay
over elements of the packed array and
the compiler you know according to the
type system then it'll run it in the
compiler otherwise it'll unpack it
so let me understand that again map f
onto a packed array it tries to compile
f knowing the type of the packed array
so
not just
it it compiles map
with that f
so it it compiles the whole map i see
but it does that
it just does that as soon as it sees
that there's a packed array inside a map
it tries to compile the whole thing
correct correct and there's a there's an
option and people run into this every so
often
that switches over to doing this if the
length is longer and it has caches and
things like that so right now remember
it's not unsuccessful yeah
correct it's not unsuccessful no i think
it's very successful but i guess just
just as a
right but so i guess if the f if the
function is x plus a hash plus one
that's no problem if the function is
anything more complicated though right
it basically the result will not be a
packed array well anything well no no
anything symbolic or known to produce a
non-symbolic thing like art right it
produces pies which are clearly not okay
guys guys guys
if i'm understanding correctly what
happens is if the type signature of f
in the compiler is mapping whatever the
type signature of the packed array is
back to that same type signature then
all as well
yep otherwise it isn't okay with the
functions is sort of polymorphic so
you know there has to be a version of
that function known to the compiler so
yeah
but yeah but if it mapped a packed array
of integers into a packed array of reals
would this still work or not absolutely
you can do map of n over
right it's totally happy but if you do
if you did it
sorry i mean if you mapped a packed rave
integers to factory integers but the
mapping function f was some really
complicated thing that the current dumb
compiler can't do
then
at the end say
is this thing that i got back something
that is repackable it does it could do
that but it doesn't
okay all right fine
yeah anyway the point the point i was
trying to make here is that
if
while we're in the process of producing
all this new technology
we find out that one of the new lower
level data structures supports say
packed strings in some situations we
could plug that in into the
the thing but it's not going to be the
scaffold array that gets that becomes
individual it's a lower level thing
better
i mean yes both things are transparent
both
look scaffolded array
is a visible head that has the
responsibility for mediating between the
part numbers you're asking for and
whatever the little creature inside the
little thing that just returns numbers
based on integer indices or something is
and so if if scaffolded array is given a
linked list or is given some arrow
string packed thingy
then its responsibility is to make the
transducer effectively not in in some
sense of that word that goes from the
translator that goes between the raw
internal data structure and the external
request for parts
does that make sense to everybody
yeah
and that's a different thing from
eventually scaffolded array itself could
be invisible and then all of that then
there is there's two levels of
invisibility the the wrapper is
invisible and the details of what the
internal data structure
uh is are transparent so to speak yeah
and and my my claim was that
if you're in the business of packing
strings most of the internal
implementation of the scaffolded array
will not make sense because you
absolutely don't want to pack five
strings by bringing them out of core
so that's why i don't think it should be
the scaffolded array that becomes
invisible but the lower level data
structure itself like you won't find i
don't understand this okay you're making
the point okay look look at the existing
packed array implementation
what is the case okay i understand the
confusion and the point here i think
the existing case if you say packed
array you really mean make it packed
but even though when you use table for
example there may be cases where you
don't in fact make a pact array you make
an ordinary list and it's only three
elements long for example am i making
sense
so the confusion here is could
scaffolded array
contain a non-packed object could one of
its possible data structures along with
linked lists and and you know packed
arrays and whatever else be
the non-packed object
we call that expression
yeah understand it so yeah
right so if it does that then all we
have to do is melt away the scaffolded
array and we would have something which
will work in all the cases we don't have
to worry about two different cases of is
there a scaffold at a rail isn't there a
scaffolded array yeah yeah but the
reason why we're doing these things
where up to a certain length we uh
do it as an expression and then we
compile and so on is because having
finer grain control on what whether or
not you pack or not is something that
makes a lot of sense for for efficiency
yes and
the contract with
the rules that if you start out with an
out-of-court thing you stay within the
realm of out-of-court things you will
not do
crazy that's a detailed question about
the heuristics of scaffolded array and
the various options that you give it and
so on i don't think that's germane to
what we're dealing with right now so
stephen
let me slightly object to this uh i
think the main point that carlo is
making is that the richness of the
underlying lower level interfaces will
always be higher than the richness of
the common denominator that the
scaffolded array is going to be
and therefore there necessarily will be
cases where people would actually have
to
go down to lower level
things and we might want to think what
this representation should be sure
that's fine although i think it will be
a scaffolded array with an option or an
argument that says what that lower level
thing is
i don't see why we shouldn't i think
it's going to be a mistake because i
think that a lot of people will expect
the kind of translation layer that
scaffolded array provides but sure if
you want to take the inner thing out
remember that the inner thing you take
out its way of having uh parts extracted
may depend on what it was that you got
out
you see what i'm saying you may need to
do that by hand if you take out the
inner object
absolutely i don't think people aren't
going to want to do that but it's okay
if they want to do that fine this design
is not good but we're seeing here
someone like
we're not we're like if we're making
this packing and packing thing
transparent
in the kernel it's not going to be any
old user it's going to be right i think
we understand this i think this is fine
i think you know there isn't any problem
here let's keep going stephen
i would like to make one slightly
tangential point which is
um
originally structured array was just
structured array and all the different
types were
structured array
and then you complained and so now we
have quantity array and we have
symmetrized array
and we have you know not yet
exposed to users but you know hilbert
matrix and whatever other
permutation matrix whatever other
structured arrays we have are their own
separate heads
so
i'm okay with trying to pack as much as
possible and to scaffold the array but
i i'm just
well i think
that in that direction once and then i
think it's not the same course it i i
don't think it's the same use case
here's the difference i think that this
is primarily for data sets and that kind
of operations what we're talking about
here
the the the kind of structure arrays
we've talked about is for computational
efficiency for representation and
computation efficiency but they are
basically numerical arrays even if they
can be symbolic but they're they're no
strings which i'm saying it's not that's
not what they're sort of designed for
well a symmetrized right look i think
the other way to say this is a
symmetrized array has a global property
about it
whereas i don't think well
i don't know a symmetrized array might
fit in here but i agree with roger
there's a a little bit of a different
kind of story
but it's a good point to ty that we've
we've gone in the direction of
introducing
uh sort of separate heads and now we're
going in a different direction okay but
that is the point i'm making i i see you
tight i know that's a fair point so the
the
it's exactly what you said
we did have a generic name structured
array for all of them
but
we've now made the capability that they
can be called what they are
so i'm saying because it was
incomprehensible to people to use
quantity i mean
in a perfect world the quantity array
would not exist that would all be
transparent
okay i think we've made the cost be
you know not high to have this um
customers i mean the the problem is
we've got now geoposition arrays and all
kinds of different arrays and we would
like to be able to just use
in perfect world this scaffolded array
thing just won't exist except for expert
users and it will simply be
transparently used but i think a key use
case for scaffolded array
is basically like a data frame where you
have different types per dimension yes
yes yes yes sure you know and and that's
just not the case for an america race
they're they're sort of all fine
that's true
let's move on i think we i think we
understand roughly what to do here
okay and also we are talking about going
in both directions if we have a data
structure thing that's lower level so we
you can you know
let's talk about indirect operations
here this this idea of
uh the object still so carla you said
you had a demo of this is that correct
yeah i didn't show you it's not white
like that but yeah i can show you
something okay go ahead one thing that
would be good to see
is because i don't think that for those
those data frames can what are the
operations that you're going to do
repeatedly i think they're going to be
very close to data set like operations
and so i think that they're
what is the catalog of key operations
yeah that would be really interesting to
see
it'll be very similar to what you do on
data set as you say okay all right let's
take a look at this okay so basically uh
right here i'm using the class
system that is in the compiler
uh so i mean i have the definition of a
class in a dm file somewhere in a
package and i create a database table
class so this thing is pointing this is
seven levels too complicated okay what
we looked at before
this is not for this is not for kids
this is like the kind of lower level
thing it's like that's not what we were
talking about before what we're talking
about before let's review what we were
talking about before
what we have right now is this idea that
you have to say you know sorted
uh
oh gosh what is it called um what is
that what is it sorted entity class oh
okay yes sorted entity costs
um
okay that you have to use that okay
whereas what we were talking about now
is that you could just say sort
and that sort if fed a database object
would return another database object
that represents the sorted entity class
yeah but this is how you get there okay
just let's review where we're trying to
get to but right now
what we have is this unevaluated sorted
entity class
that is
um that represents a sorted version of
the entity class right
yeah
okay so the alternative design would be
that there is a symbolic thing that
represents you know whatever the the
database handle i don't know what we
want to call it is it database object or
is it database data object or what is it
the thing that is going into the ring
it's a scuffle disarray
like it it does so
i i think
no it's not
let me know
like let me give you an example you
would have something which is like data
frame or school array whatever you want
to call it you call take
on that take two let's say that means
like
column wise take the first two rows
and
the how do you translate that to a lower
level thing that is called limit i mean
in this case it's called limit because
that's what it's called in sql
on the lower level data structure that
returns another lower level data
structure that didn't actually perform
the operation to get data out you have
to do objects
get data
this is all irrelevant okay i mean this
is implementation details the question
is what's the design
and but this is important to me because
i think that what you're what we're
doing is
we are just saying
in order to work with scaffold array
which take which supports take
then the inside data structure needs to
support something that is take like
and that can be done with you know
string parameters like for data
structure i don't care it doesn't matter
it just has to implement these two three
things
wait a second that's not the design
we're talking about okay the design
we're talking about is
not having to do sorted entity costs
right right now you build up hold on you
build up this
unevaluated sorted entity class of
filtered entity class blah blah blah
blah blah and then what is it entity
list finally does the evaluation is that
correct
uh
okay okay so the existing
approach
is
things like entity value
of sorted entity class blah blah blah
okay so now what we're now saying is
that instead of doing that
we would be able to say
uh sort of database object and that
would return a database object now
something has to resolve that database
object what would resolve it
why database object and not just generic
scaffold array
and presumably that sort is sort by
don't you think oh no it might just be
sword
steven may i uh make a few comments on
this uh
uh because yeah i don't think sword
actually makes sense right the sword is
doing the cannot the canonical
expression sort and which i you know for
an out of core how do you do the
canonical expression sort well i know if
it's a bunch of numbers you can do a
sort on them
well
one problem here why sort of entity
class was brought into this game
at all was that sorting semantics might
be slightly different for different
sort of
things that we work with like for
instance for databases and the question
then is do we want sword to follow well
from language semantics
then we can use sword or do we want to
be closer to the semantics what we've
got right now is close to unusable
let's call a spade a spade
it's you know it is only usable by
somebody who makes a big investment and
is prepared to dive into something which
is at least as complicated as sql
i think
so we didn't succeed in building
something which is right now we didn't
succeed in building something where we
have greatly it's very nice that it
exists in the language
okay but i don't think it exists well in
the language
uh one thing i wanted to say to this
steven is that uh this line this
primitives like sort identity class and
others were absolutely necessary within
the entity approach so as soon as we
decided that our front-end for
databases would be entities as a first
front-end
we were kind of forced by the design to
do this and the second thing is
these things these inert queries are
they actually give huge power to more
advanced users although admittedly they
might be less intuitive
for lessons
this is the right way to do it we should
have had an object which is transformed
by these queries and the result here can
represent symbolically inside that
database object it's very similar to the
scaffolded array idea
it's not
it's not it's not but that's exactly the
problem because within the entity world
there is no such object that we could uh
use like that
except object
within the entity world you don't have
such an object to work on because all
you have is
uh you know some entity classes or
whatnot they are not directly such an
object that is being transformed i know
what do you mean if you run sort of
entity class as opposed to sort of
database object
right yes yes
right okay
right so we need some kind of indirect
object and we need that to represent i
mean we could imagine
you know some kind of entity object i'm
not necessarily suggesting that but you
know that's the indirect object that
represents
i don't understand why we made all this
nice discussion about having one object
for several different backhands
which could be databases could be arrow
could be par k could be whatever and now
you we are talking about just having a
database object again like the interface
is exactly the same okay
okay
perhaps it can be merged but the first
step is can we take the existing
sorted entity class
structure
and turn it the other way around and
have it be applied to a single symbolic
object
yeah it already works like that
internally pretty much so it's not it's
just a matter of deciding on the syntax
and documenting it but i don't see why
we need to do it twice if we're gonna do
scaffold array
or whatever that's a different point
you're making a different point
i'm trying to understand
is it the case that you could make this
work
so in other words yes you're right this
internal thing might just be whatever we
end up calling scaffolded array
which might have some more general name
perhaps even data frame but i don't
think that's quite right
uh data container steven i think it will
be a matter of just 10 or 15 lines of
code to implement uh you know okay on
top of this object based on the
databases
no no no you it depends really depends
on what the interface is um
yes but i mean the basic the basics 20
functions then yes it's it's it's
and if you do it throughout values then
yes it's 20 lines of code but if you
want to support hundreds of functions
i'm not saying production level i'm
saying just to listen let's do the
experiment yes let's make something
experimentally you know maybe for the
sake of not having us be confused let's
call this data container for now
okay instead of scaffolded array
does that make sense to people
i i think that's an important point
because if we call it a scaffolded array
somehow we expect it to behave like an
array even to be array queue and so it
will not have the power that a more
general object like a database
fine so let's say it's called data
container for now
data container is a bit too vague on
what the shape of the data is
like
well
okay hold on hold on what is the shape
of the data
is the shape of the data lists of
associations
so to speak no it's association of lists
but yeah well
no no you can't say that it's got to be
an arbitrary mixture of lists and
associations
no no no carlo
carlo you can implement the two-level
case
using database technology we are going
to support the multi-level case even if
it can be implemented then you even if
it cannot be implemented through
database technology am i making sense
i don't think you are but i'm fine
what do you have to say about that
that i i think that the only way to
support a large number of things
efficiently is to constrain the shape of
the data
right right so we're not going to
constrain our language because you know
in the 1960s somebody thought databases
were just tables okay not happening
then we don't need a different head
what are you talking about what you're
describing is dataset
it supports arbitrarily nested data it
has its own internal type system it can
you know
but
the points it's like in the same way
they're packed arrays that you know if
you if you do the most if your data is
in the most general format then it's not
going to be particularly efficient but
if your data happens to be in the right
format then it will be much more
efficient
right i mean presumably it's just
if you know that that for example uh uh
that that uh you know lists of associate
things that are basically a big list of
associations
is uh you know that will be internally
stored as a database then you can store
your data like that but then you know if
you import database you can bring into
that format and so on but then you know
and it will run much faster but then you
can also presumably do it in other
formats and it just will be slower
right so then the question is could we
merge scaffolded array or data container
into dataset
i don't know
but the whole point is initially in
terms of how we get there we're going to
implement these things as different
heads so we're not confused about having
some auto magic thing that that doesn't
work most of the time
you know they may never make it into
production version with separate heads
but for our internal purposes here we're
going to implement them with separate
heads so we can see what's going on does
that make sense to people
and so for example carlo can implement
his two level thing
with its own head and it's only two
level and we see what happens
and then we see how a nosql database can
be implemented as a back end you know
for example using our sparkle stuff or
something like that
with
with uh
you know with without that restriction
and with a different head injury blowing
away the whole idea of having an
internal api for these guys so everyone
who re-rolled the robot
no no wrong wrong completely wrong
completely wrong
each one of these things
no that's just completely wrong
the internal api
when you call your two-level stuff with
an internal api that requests a
three-level object it will fail that's
that's what it might be what i'm asking
is
there is a very limited number of things
you can do to a two level thing it
doesn't matter whether it's backed by a
database or it's backed by arrow that's
also two level
now if if if you
do for each of these things a separate
head and that head has to understand
sort and join and whatnot
then you're making us do the work
separately multiple times for all
different backhands oh yeah okay
move on with this discussion i think
you're confused
right i think this is not
no
i'm i'm simply saying
i'm simply saying don't do something
where there is a monolithic project that
involves building a single head that has
all possible things in it that's the
wrong way to do this project that's all
i'm saying
that's not what i want to do what i want
to do is to build something that is like
data structure that has like string
methods
and then we we can make it look like
different heads that get that ingest
here's the design that i want to see
right
the design i want to see is this thing
we've described this data container
thing
let's see this particular very simple
thing which leonard has said is 20 lines
of code
this this just
you know this refactoring of the way
that we deal with symbolic entity
classes
okay let's see that
as a separate thing to experiment with
let's try and start seeing this data
container thing
and yes
you can implement this data container
thing for the two level case we can
implement it for multi-level case with
different backing technology
and then let's figure out can it be
merged into data set
can it be made to be completely
transparent etc does that make sense
uh i think one of the key questions to
ask right away is whether we're fine
with failing on all
operations which we explicitly can't
support
for now yes
that's what i just said for now just
fail okay
we understand later on we will want to
do something where we have basically an
option whether we want to fail
or go and unpack it effectively does
that make sense
yes yeah no
okay
christopher am i missing something
here i don't know why you're asking me
but i think well i was picking you out
because because you stayed on top of
what was going on
i just want to say that i am now
confused about what the scope of
scaffold to the rays are
and i mean i was thinking rectangular or
possibly close to rectangular with you
know some raggedness
that's what i was thinking as well
okay
that's what i'm thinking as well i'm
thinking it's the most common cases
that for which there is the most
alternate technology to deal with them
and then the more ragged cases either
you know
slight raggedness might be handled in
the wrapper
or slight raggedness says we punt just
like we do for pactorize
does that make sense although i think
rob is working on the
right on a
version of factories that can be ragged
okay well lovely that's magnificent but
um
right yes but right so if right so then
write data sorry data data
um
uh yes i'm i'm blanking uh the structure
data container
uh no the data set that's what i'm
trying to say sorry too many words
beginning with data um data set
represents right very k or at least can
represent very non-rectangular things
indeed
right so so and and that's so if if
we're saying that scaffold that arrays
are really rectangular or close to
rectangular i i think it's a good idea
from data set no no but you guys keep on
getting confused okay okay just like
with packed array
with data set if your data set happens
to be rectangular then we can use faster
better stronger out of core whatever
else techniques
if it isn't of that form then we have to
fall back to our general expression
structure
and that's fine it sort of sounds like
maybe this is i mean maybe calling this
the future of a raised meeting
i mean i don't know it well
i mean it seems like what we're at this
point talking about is just that
you know just as we have packed arrays
as sort of a secret way that what looks
like an expression can be stored more
efficiently we're basically just talking
about generalizing that to lots of other
types of expressions now most notably
other big container types like list of
associations and quantity arrays and so
on but maybe also to other you know
other other things i mean things that
might be more nosqlike where they might
be pretty you know
like json stuff like that i don't know i
mean it just it seems like we're talking
about is more general than just arrays
though yes although it could perfectly
well start with a raise because i think
arrays are the most important case
special technologies
right unless
sorry i i think the the key object here
is lists
and associations so combinations and
lists
of
lists and associations are the thing to
go but will they be rectangular or can
they be ragged in your view
in my view they could also be rugged
with these new ideas that i was
mentioning that rob and i are discussing
but also by the way i mean
there's also the aspect of things like
quantity array where that's not really
about it being
in lists or associations it's about
you know a symbolic wrapper but yeah
sure yes but anything related to
structure array is an array a structural
array objects are array cube so those
are pure arrays and rectangular so they
are the easy case in my view
okay
what we need is three generalizations
one is
list plus associations the second is
ruggedness the third is types
and i think that we want missings like
that
that's a detail in the sense of because
we kind of have
talking data science
deeper level than two is a detail
missing is a key feature
well
like what's the relation between missing
and ruggedness
can i say that missing objects are just
rocket options no because ragged is is
only cuts things off at the end
yeah missing is more important than
rugged in in data science
in in general if you look yeah i mean we
need a mechanism for dealing with but
again there's a lot of algorithm stuff
which roger can speak to that for
supporting missing which we do not have
yet is that a first statement roger
yeah but but the case that we are
discussing here um
i agree that it's sort of if it's going
to be data set then missing handling is
kind of a key
[Music]
key feature
for those
sorry say that again
yeah yes there's a bunch of things that
we're missing but when missing is in a
particular context it's not so hard to
actually build it so in the context of
data set it's not as hard as in general
you know
in time series it's not as hard as in
general
yeah right i agree i agree that's what
we should be concentrating on because
those are the important cases exactly
okay so
again stephen one little thing that
i was trying to understand from
discussion before uh
there was i mean there's always here a
trade-off between efficiency
and um
generality and
uh
are we more focused on the efficiency in
this case yeah we kind of want to do the
general ideas okay let me explain again
let me explain again we want to do the
same thing we've done with packed arrays
if it fits the template to be blindingly
fast have it be blindingly fast if it
breaks the template have it fall through
into the high functionality slower
capabilities and i fully expect to have
a variable that's a terabyte database i
mean why couldn't you yeah right but
that's fine but it will be a very
structured thing that doesn't have all
kinds of weird ragged tentacles hanging
out yeah right and as long as it's i'm
i'm safely inside i'm perfectly fine
just uh so you need to be able to
control it very carefully well the issue
is this the issue is what about the
corner cases where somebody thought it
was packed but they have two
two missings too many and the thing
unpacks right that's the awkward case
that's a case we were fighting for many
years with back to rise
once we get the main part of this built
we need to figure out better how to
message and control those corner cases
you know there's not a problem for us to
have a billion by billion matrices in
fact we do in graph theory
yeah if if you try to you know make it i
understand so this sparse arrays is an
example of a success story where people
do not typically get confused
by
you know again yeah
it's
i i think the answer to julio's question
is what i said namely if it fits the
template it needs to be fast if it
doesn't we don't care
right it just has to work
makes sense but we don't want a
situation where people say
that oh you broke out of the template so
we're going to fail completely
that's not what we want
but we need to be able to obtain in that
situation and and i think users need to
be able to if we don't yeah
i agree right i agree but the default
will end up being that it defaults to
it's just going to work even if it's not
as efficient
okay sorry i just wanted to be reassured
probably with some guard rails that say
if it's going to unpack to a petabyte of
data you've got to not do it
so i mean or or just orders i mean the
thing we were talking about earlier
about how there could be a head like the
packed array head that doesn't exist
that that basically will not let it
unpack without fine then it would fail
that's that sounds like a fine solution
okay there's some comments from a live
stream let's see
uh
someone asking about type system that
jose
demoed at
the 2020 technology conference
apparently what was that jose
yes so
so yes in that in that conference i
demoed some sort of vc version i was
working on for data set
of of the old type system in i mean the
the one that we still have
and yes i i never got to to
reach it to the point that it was ready
for production
what is that is that a speed up of data
set itself or what
it was a speed up of the computation of
the type of data set
because it was
the type system that tally constructed
in top level i moved it to c
but okay but is that type system
something that could be compiled by the
new compiler
it doesn't need to be compiled it's it's
purely in c code
i mean i i was trying to make it as fast
as i could it's just that i never made
it to work exactly as the current type
system and so
it's just
it's going to change
the things i understand what i'm asking
is could we take telly's code and simply
compile it with a new compiler rather
than having to rewrite it and see
well it relies a lot on the pattern
matcher and things like that okay fine
so the answer is no
right so
okay but you have an implementation
which should probably be finished
yes i just need to find time and
all right or somebody else should do it
i mean it's it's a thing to be done
okay we should make sure that's on
sushma's project list i was not aware of
it
um
let's see uh
um okay
let's
briefly talk about our two
other
what's this current missing features
what is this this is what we discussed
before this is this is prior to this
note 04 correct
scott is this can you comment on that
please
what is this relationship of this agenda
to what we have in o4 here
i think these are details that were in
the first agenda of the first meeting
i see okay all right fine okay so let's
go back to this
okay
so the next one is
uh sort of
remote asset
arrays
i think would be a better way to put it
okay of the kind that we have with the
mongodb
system
that we built
what's the relationship of that to these
things here that is that that is
like a scaffolded array
perhaps it is a scaffolded array i'm not
sure except that it feels like there's
now three levels
there's the wrapper provided by the
scaffolding which is does essentially
address you know index translation
there's the structure of the array
and then hanging off that structure
might be you know a hundred megabyte
images
in each slot of the array if you
understand what i'm saying
do you understand what i'm saying oh
yeah actually it's not so much different
from some forms of lazy lists that i was
discussing last time if they are filed
back it's essentially a similar idea
yes okay
okay
so
my question is um
that's the chunked lists etc right out
of core chunk lists
um so question
it's
the mongodb system that we built right
we have a fairly complete link there
is that integratable into this framework
that we're talking about right now
for arrays
i assume that for certain operations yes
i mean there are some things you can do
there but uh
we will need to see the specifics
right but so is the correct way to think
about that
something like a scaffold what is this
as i say it's another level
there's okay so let's list out
levels okay so there's one level is
essentially index translation
i.e wrapper
of data
container does that make sense
the next level is
uh
you know
array backbone
and the final level is
array element contents
does that make sense to distinguish
those
and what do you mean by array backbone
is this uh the internal implementation
for each case or
yes that that's whatever it is whether
it's a you know a pure array a linked
list whatever it is right it's the thing
that stores it has
this contains
the
full
enumeration of all elements
okay
whereas this says
this is
specific blobs of data for each element
does that make sense to
people anybody
oh yes
i think you're referring to types at the
very
last line the other one i'm
[Music]
not sure that we can always
distinguish between the backbone
and uh specific elements uh it's rather
that
the backbone can have kind of pointers
to
yes
correct that is correct optionally right
the backbone could contain everything
the backbone could contain could either
contain the data directly
or contain or have pointers to data
yeah but i i also think it it might not
make entire sense to completely split
those the first two things
in that
i mean if we're if we want to do
efficient things with
with arrays
basically listability is the default
single object operations what are you
talking about what we've been talking
about all along here is the whole point
is we have a bunch of technologies for
storing arrays with particular index
structures
right like pure integer indices
right but we want to be able to think of
those arrays in the the analogous
expression in the top level language has
associations with symbolic keys
right
does that make sense
yes it does make sense but what i'm
talking there's a big distinction
between the column indices and the row
indices here
oh gosh come on you can't
no because this was a big mistake with
the whole entity stuff like you almost
never wanted to enter the list and pick
a single entity that's degenerate kids
you always want to do listable things
work on entity classes
the rows might or might not be labeled
the rows might just be a list or they
might be labeled with names you know
carlo itali you know leonid et cetera et
cetera et cetera as rose right with with
with
with association like keys for the rows
or the or the rows might happen to be a
list of rows
can't we see when can we just say
instead of index translation something
more general like
some index related metadata or
yes that's fine that's fine but the main
point is what is the translation from
what is stored inside to the as if
expression external form
right that's all we're talking about
there
well in general it's going to be uh you
know this wasn't the point i was making
in this part but we already talked about
this up here right we already talked
about
how we deal with
you know
what we can do to the elements to
translate from what they are on the
outside to what they are on the inside
there are two things that can get
translated there can be the index can be
translated and there can be wrapping of
the expression itself for example
putting in units
yeah what i'm saying is that most of
those things will happen at the same
time anyway so it will not happen that's
fine that wasn't the point we were
making here the point we were making
here is
that what we're trying to say here
um
um
what i'm trying to talk about here
is this case
the specific case that we're dealing
with of
can we have using mongodb or something
like that can we have something where
what matters is you know where we have
very large amounts of data hanging off
pointers where most of the time we don't
do anything with those images we just
move them around
do you see what i'm saying
yeah i'm pretty sure we can yeah with
[ __ ] you mean
yes i know but that's a new technology
that's a different technology that's not
databases that are not sql like
databases that's not uh you know apache
arrow that's a different technology so
i'm saying it's not leonid's chunk to
chunk list technology it's a different
technology so what i'm saying is
you know
are we going to be able to get that
as a piece of this story and do we need
a different top-level mechanism than
data container for it or is it just a
part of the data container story
you see what i'm saying
oh
i think this boils down to the interface
that we want all these things to support
and whether we want some unified
interface to be supported
because
you you we have to request which
operations
uh we want all this we want a unified
interface we clearly want a unified
interface
right so we have to be more we have to
probably be more concrete maybe not
today but at the later meetings i know i
know so what we're going to do is some
of these things will support some
operations some will support others
if you this is the whole point we don't
know what that is going to feel like yet
it may very well be that one is
completely happy with the fact that some
operations support some you know some
underlying structures support some
operations some support others that
that's just fine
am i making sense
so we got to just start building stuff
okay well maybe the idea is this i mean
that basically we want to make some
sort of uh maybe there's some minimal
set of functions that these all support
right i mean things like part and so on
but then you know if you want
then you know you can implement
transpose yourself and now transpose
would be way faster and also other
functions that rely on transpose will be
way faster and so on and so you know
maybe there's a minimal set but if you
implement more things it just makes it
more efficient
it seems reasonable to me in other words
that's obviously the right the right
thing it's not just efficient in terms
of execution time it's efficient in
terms of programmer time because you're
writing a much more abstracted set of
code that would work for many different
information
but as christopher's saying it's not you
know if you ask for transpose on
something where transpose is not
natively supported the default will be
unpacked do the transpose put it back
again
but if it turns out it's natively
supported because somebody actually
wrote that particular method for that
particular thing then great or or maybe
even apart from from unpack maybe you
can even implement it in terms of you
know the the part and a few other
functions that are the default rights
yeah i have to i have to switch i could
i can pull somebody else needs to start
sharing because i have to go somewhere
who's going to start sharing
somebody share this
scott maybe you can share this
can anybody share this please
okay if we can't do it then we have to
stop this meeting
anybody capable of sharing it or not
nope
okay then time to end the meeting um and
we will continue this
let's make sure we continue this with